à vous faire le terrible oui didier on
ne bouge pas pendant les dix mois de
cours d'hébreu journée pour ne bouge pas
pendant le génial thierry roland et je
vous préférez staline ou hitler ni l'un
ni l'autre
non les gens qui digitaline à un peu
mieux non non vous c'est pareil presse
kaka le mot le plus con en amour c'est
merci encore
ou oui oui oui oui c'est clair oui merci
c'est combien si c'est des cons eil
merci c'est vraiment né là merci madame
merci pour le petit cadeau non c'est
vous encore annoncer coup ça prévient
mais c'est fatigant alors vous partez
trois ans d'un vaisseau spatial
vous avez le choix entre trois passagers
gérard holtz
ça commence bien
charles bietry nom gérard muller et j'ai
eu chaud qu'au l'épaule enfin vous
connaissez suffisamment pour savoir bien
sûr je sais qu'il aime hiver trois
minutes mais trois ans wayne shevell
isabelle alonso surprendre oui j'ai vous
surprend ouais je prendrais gérard holtz
bah oui parce que moi me parlerait de
sport et voilà alors que miller
j'essaierai de j'essaierai de le
convaincre que je suis pas les normes
merde qui croient que je suis est
sexuellement ça vous dérange pas de pas
prendre alonso non bons acquis
accordez-vous le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes où un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieux qui se
tape des 20 jeux du stade les jeunes
déjà eu lieu
du sexe opposé c'était des mecs un ami
entre chez vous il avance chez vous
vraiment votre chambre à l'improviste
ce qui me gêne le plus qu'ils trouvent
sur la table de chevet c'est mind calmes
ou un godemiché miles away bien alors
vous préféreriez passé la nuit avec anne
sinclair lors sinclair ou bob sinclair
lors sinclair alors sinclair pas très
gentil pour anne sinclair commun c'est
pas grave c'est violent